hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
February 6 2023
's going on how are you
how's it going
um
hope everything's going good in your
world my my world was going great until
I couldn't get this [__] four-wheeler
to starting it backfired and now my ears
ringing even more than it ever did I'm
hoping that's gonna go away
um you live you learn
um
anyway
uh where to start this week you know
guys I just had such a crazy weekend
um I was watching TV last night right
and my kids they think sports are boring
it's just funny to me because I'm
totally into them but they're you know
they're young they want to watch like
cartoons and stuff my son actually
enjoys like car racing if he sees the
cars he you know he's like Dada cool
cars room room like he does that for a
minute and then he gets like bored or
whatever
so anyway I was watching uh I was like
listen I can only listen to yeah but
yeah
one more monkey fell off the Emmy
[__] times can you listen to that
before you start to slowly go insane
so I'm like all right we got to put on a
dad Channel now right
so we go you know I'm flipping through
the channels and trying to figure
something out I stop on a Jean-Claude
Van Damme thing my brain said Don't Stop
on this I'm like it's that's John Claude
his stuff wasn't too bad let me just
take a peek at this movie and he was
running on top of a train and he threw
some guy off the train well first of all
my daughter's like I don't want to watch
this I don't watch this so I said okay I
hit guide and I didn't realize it was
still in that little window
so Jean-Claude Van Damme
um [__] throws this guy
off the train and my daughter just like
freaked out
I felt like an [__] I had to be like
no it wasn't a real guy I mean it was a
real guy but it's not like
you know it's a movie or whatever and
she's just like well I just want to see
if he's okay
and I'm just sitting there that is the
sweetest thing I've ever heard in my
life and like what happens how do human
beings go from that
I don't know
you know what's funny some kids are
already [__] just like right out of
the gate you know what I mean like you
can't teach that
well actually you can with your [__]
parents Behavior
so I felt bad about that I gave her a
hug I explained what was going on
and I said you know those guys actually
make a living stuntman at least back in
the day they did I don't know about now
with the green screens and Tom Cruise I
don't think there's any [__] work
left
um
so we were flipping through and I got to
sports
[Music]
and I saw that Kyrie Irving got traded
uh from the Brooklyn Nets to the Dallas
Mavericks shout out to the Brooklyn Nets
for being like [__] you you're not going
to the Lakers I wish more teams would do
that
you know what I mean I mean how many
[__] years are the Lakers gonna have
a star player that pouts and then they
just bring in every [__] free agent
in the world for the guy
um
you know I mean what
what is there a [__] rule that like
everybody eventually has to play for the
[__] Lakers
I better be honest with you though I'm
gonna tell you this like I am going to
slowly just get out of being into sports
because
um
there was this 30 for 30 on the other
night about that great Ravens team
in 2000 that won the Cleveland Browns
slash Baltimore Ravens first Super Bowl
with at Modell
and um
he uh they were doing this whole thing
where they had all the guys
that played on the team doing this
retrospective watching video and
you know 20 years later whatever
I don't know Sarah Goose was still there
rest his soul so I know he died a few
years ago so I don't know when it was
some probably last decade and they were
looking back talking about it telling
all these funny stories there was all
this great video and everything and they
had a playoff game playoffs
playoffs you kidding me playoffs
um we'll be lucky if we get first now
um they played the Tennessee Titans
and right before the game playoff game
the Tennessee Titans one of their
assistant coaches stole the Playbook
stole the [__] Playbook and everyone
on the Titan side was fine with it and
they looked at the Playbook and they
knew everything that they were [__]
doing
they still lost the game
um
but once again this is just as a
Patriots fan I'm like where the F where
the [__] was uh Playbook gate
where was all of that [__]
why do people now you know why don't
people [__] call their feet to the
fire it's just [__]
anyway and what I'm starting to kind of
realize is that
um
you know because like you if you stole
the Playbook like what what sort of
[__] satisfaction do you have winning
that game
like what kind of a [__] person are
you that you stole the Playbook right or
a guy in your organization steals the
[__] Playbook and then you're kicking
this team's ass because you know
everything that they're gonna do and
let's just say they went on to win the
game right and then you go to the press
conference you just had a really great
game defense and you're just gonna sit
there being like well you know a defense
you know I told them they really had to
step it up this week and everybody's
just gonna go along
with the [__] everyone's just gonna
get go along with the [__] because
there's so much money
so much like accolades so many [__]
[__]
at the end of winning that game and
possibly winning a Super Bowl that you
can go to bed and be okay with that
um
I don't know the longer I watch sports
and the more I watch these guys talk
about sports and you just see [__] that
people do and pretend their headsets
went out when they didn't really go out
because they called all the plays in the
first half and all of that [__] the more
I just watch this [__] and now you see
that they're they're
in bed you can like they're making money
off of sports gambling
and I guess they're all kind of like uh
registered as entertainment leaks I
thought it was just the NFL it's just
starting to make me think like
uh what the [__] am I watching here
look I'm not gonna be the guy that says
it's all [__] fixed I I've just
maintained for a while that it is a
business and certain teams get more
ratings than other teams the Lakers
evidently
[__] uh Mr Stern there that's you
who's who's your dream final Lakers
versus the Lakers he said that
right that shady [__]
um who leaked the Donahue story so he
they could get out in front of it and
all that I believe all of that stuff
um
I don't know man like
I always [__] that I don't have any
free time what if I just walked away
from Sports
okay
and was just left with my own demons
and I had to work those out and then I
had to actually figure out who I am as a
person
or
I could continue down this road
and tell you guys that I saw a clip
of an interview with Patrick Mahomes dad
and he seems like the coolest dude on
Earth and also seems like just like a
throwback
like they don't make guys like that
anymore like that guy sounds like guy
sounded like when I was growing up
um
just sounded like the coolest dude ever
so that was funny because I was sitting
there
going who do I want to because you know
I don't give a [__] about either team
um
I don't know that's the great thing
though
about this you know my team had a great
run
a couple of decades there and it sucks
that we kind of suck now but this time
of year
is actually kind of enjoyable I find
well it's just like ah it's not my tape
I don't have to get I can just sit here
and eat dip and enjoy this [__] oh it's
going to be phenomenal
um
underrated your team not making the
playoffs
then you can just enjoy the playoffs I
got like most of my friends out here a
lot of 49er fans
uh um who else
mainly 49er fans and like they were in a
walking depression for like three
[__] days
after that game
um
and uh
I'm sitting there alone I know what the
[__] that feels like you think that's
bad try losing a Super Bowl all the
Super Bowl losses
the bears oh
the Packers
the Giants the Giants again
the Eagles one was just weird though
we'll tell you that that Eagles one was
like what the [__] did I just watch
there was like one punt the whole game
um
anyway listen to me I'm just babbling on
like that person that you like you know
you pretend to be asleep next to when
you're on a plane and they just sit
there talking to the side of your face
um here I am 10 minutes in
done nothing but talk about sports for
the most part other than shitty kids I
believe
um all right here's the deal I think the
I think the Kansas City Chiefs are going
to win
um
I think in order for the Eagles to win
for some reason I just feel like uh
Jalen hurts is gonna have to have the
Vince Young first USC game
which he very well could I don't know I
got two kids I I barely watch this [__]
anymore I just I like the BTK Killer's
Brother Andy Reed
um just them being there before and I
think Casey actually has a halfway
decent
defense which they usually don't their
defense usually sucks
um but they're actually playing pretty
good so
uh
I don't know
I have no idea I'm gonna root for the
Eagles though just because I hate the
[__] purse throw
it's a forward lateral I think there's
enough advantages
you know what I should do I'm gonna post
this picture of Ben Davidson tackling uh
Bob Griese it's a classic
um
NFL photo
what used to be able they used to try to
break quarterbacks in half
like literally
like they wanted to snap you in half at
the [__] waist and have you carried
off in a Stretcher like you were like
you were on a Battlefield
um
I don't know anyway
so that's the deal Kyrie Irving went to
the Dallas Mavericks
and uh
um I don't know
am I happy about that I don't give a
[__] do I give a [__] I don't think I
give a [__] anymore maybe maybe I could
just be that guy hey Bill maybe he could
stop being so self-involved and talk
about something else all right I got
something for you
um this weekend me and a buddy of mine
went to go see Paul Anka at this theater
that nobody seems to know how to
pronounce
I think it's s-a-b-a-n or
s-a-b-b-a-n or e-n and I never is it the
the sabbin
the Saban
the saw band
let's see man I don't know how to say
but I went there to go see Paul Anka
um he has one of my favorite albums of
all time this guy he you know he wrote
the theme of The Tonight Show
he wrote the lyrics to my way the whole
Arrangement and all that for when Frank
was going to retire in 71 he wrote songs
for Sammy Davis Jr he wrote songs for
Barbra Streisand and oh by the way he
wrote a bunch of songs for himself the
guy was born in 1941 I think he made it
by the time he was 15 he's been famous
for like 70 [__] years
been singing his ass off for 70 years
and this guy came out there and I'm
telling you right now like have you ever
seen Tony Bennett how Tony Bennett
sounds like he did in the 1960s still
like one of the only guys ever Paul
ankus the same way he absolutely
absolutely destroyed
he destroyed me and my buddy were just
looking at each other first of all we
just kept going he wrote this song too
and then he would sing it
like the recording
he did this thing where he he did a
video thing where he was showing um
Sammy Davis Jr in a song he wrote for
him and Sammy was singing this song and
Paul comes in and sings the high Harmony
on it at 81 that Sam is singing like 40
50 years ago absolutely killed was an
incredible shape
you could tell he looked thrilled to be
there
um I'm not going to tell you too many
things because I don't I don't want to
you know
go see the show
I'll tell you this if you got a uh
you got something coming up you know
that you got to take your wife to or
something like that you're just like a
nice
classy evening
of uh
music or whatever like me my buddy we
dressed up we wore suits and everything
you know why was that a respect
um
some people just showed up looking like
animals man
it was a guy a few seats away from us I
swear to God
he had a leather jacket from like I
think 1991 Maybe 89.
waist length
do you know the remember when they had
like the shoulder pads it literally
looked you know and they would have like
a different design for the shoulder pads
it looked like waffle iron imprints
and I will tell you this that
was a badass jacket
in the late 80s
early 90s there was there was some
hideous
there was a lot of cows that laid down
their [__] lives for some of the
ugliest leather jackets ever made
um I'm just waiting for uh
some hipster will bring it back
we'll bring back like the mullet is back
but I also think I don't think the
mullet will ever come back with hipsters
because I think they align that with
like conservative thought
and and um
voting for uh Trump and Bush and all of
those guys but that would be funny
liberal hipsters
dressing like you know they always like
dress like a character
I saw these two just I mean there's no
other word from just two [__]
jerk-offs
and they were looking at some old church
and I was thinking like oh God they're
probably going to turn it into a club
sort of a closed down church or whatever
and um
just one of the guys the way he was
dressed
it was a combination of like James Dean
and Little House in the prairie but you
look at the guy you could tell he never
had a fight in his life right just
[__] one of those guys that you know
those people that go to a coffee shop
and they come out and it's looks like
they went to like an like an ice cream
factory or something Ice Cream Factory a
parlor
I bypassed where the regular guy goes
they're buying they're buying that ice
cream and gulp in bulk in gulp I said
now you know these people that the
Frappuccino
you know what I mean I love the
frappucci it's just like
just in case you weren't getting enough
[__] sugar in your diet let's just
start off let's just start the day
by drinking all the calories that you
need in a day none of which your body
can use
wouldn't it be amazing if the government
just stepped in we wouldn't let them do
it though you know I'm an American I can
eat what I want to eat
I want freedom a choice you know I will
pick my poison
which I believe in a lot
um
but I will tell you though the [__]
to start your [__] day with that [__]
it's almost like the government needs to
step in
some people like a government that
leaves you alone
um I don't
um
but I think they shouldn't but my
problem with our government is not that
they don't leave me alone
um it's that they don't that they don't
that corporate corporations aren't
saying the same thing I mean they do say
it
but this whole [__] thing where uh
everybody goes you know like you know
let business build and blah blah blah
these guys are [__]
lunatics
[__] lunatic someone was telling me
the other day that all of this [__] that
they're making that's that we're buying
and it's destroying the environment
they're going to put it on the consumer
and they're not going to change anything
and these [__] politicians aren't
going to say a [__] word about it and
neither is you know oh [__]
hoity-toity CNN and then the red [__]
on [__] Fox none of them are gonna
say anything
they won't say a [__] word about it
other than blaming each other's Channel
um
it's one of the worst card tricks out
there and somehow I don't understand how
people
so many well I do
actually I do understand
because uh there's just a lot of people
out there that are uh not smart
and God made them
all right and he and we have no one to
blame but him I'm into that right now
I'm into blaming God
laughs
I think it's high time we hold the man
upstairs accountable for his work
you know
listen I can forgive a mouth-breathered
[__] I am one right but a mouth
breathing [__] with no empathy that
walks around thinking they know
everything that's that's the one that I
uh
I don't know
you know not those [__] complete
morals you ever see like you know what
you know what's worse you ever see like
these motivational speakers and they'll
be in some conference room in some
shitty hotel
and they're up there and they're just
[__] talking these these these people
they just they don't have a [__]
prayer
right they're smart enough to know that
they're not going to get it from church
all right
and why is that because the Devil Wears
Prada
you know I've never I've seen
the same scene in that movie about 40
times my wife loves that movie
loves that movie and Meryl Streep you
know playing I guess the devil
um
there's like four or five of those
movies that they're on TV all the time
and I've seen bits and pieces of the
whole movie but I've never sat down and
watched the whole thing like I've never
seen Greece but every time it comes on
they're always in the LA River
getting ready to have the race and I
always watch the race I always forget
who wins
it was a black car and a white car
and one of the cars I think the white
car was Grease Lightning it was John
Travolta and the guy from Taxi rest his
soul
um
yeah
I think that was it I never seemed to
see that one I finally [__] saw West
Side Story I watched Steven Spielberg's
um remake of it which I loved and then I
watched I went I watched the original
one I loved that one too just beautiful
shot movies I don't know you know
but you guys have it's probably people
like you guys
out there or like me I should say
there was a lot of that when I first
started comedy people like you never saw
Willy Wonka in the Chocolate Factory
it's like I I didn't
I didn't we we
used to go to violent movies it was
funny like my mother took us to [__]
two kid movies and she told me years
later she was like yeah we went to him I
just thought they were stupid
[Laughter]
I know I've told this story before
it was uh we saw uh for the love of
Benji
which I imagine my mother watching it
was like for the love of God kill that
[__] dog and let's get out of here
and then there was um
For the Love of Benji oh my God I mean
could there be a more saccharine
[__] movie out there that's like you
know what really made Like Bugs Bunny
and uh Sesame Street like all of those
like they knew how to entertain kids and
and but also
kept in mind that there were adults
watching the kids or with an earshot and
they made it entertaining for them
um but then there's just people they
were just like let's torture the adults
and just make this 100 for the kids and
they made [__] like for the love of
Benji
which was some sort of it was like home
alone with like a [__] beagle or
something I don't know what it was it
was it was
I I don't remember I just can't imagine
the poor people who had to shoot that
[__] movie
trying to get that [__] dog to do
whatever the hell it was supposed to do
you know
um and then we saw Herby goes to Monte
Carlo which was basically Knight Rider
in a Volkswagen
so Knight Rider was cool because it had
David Hasselhoff with a cool down David
Hasselhoff had a cool leather jacket in
the 80s
um
but uh
I think they when did they get bad there
was some time when they started doing
the designs on the [__] shoulders
different texture just to sort of break
it up for the eye keep it interesting
for the eye whatever the [__] they did
um yeah we saw those and then the next
movie we saw
was some disco movie about a vampire
I can't remember I just remember it
ended with the Vampire finally bit the
chick on the neck and she turned into a
bat and the final movie was he was kind
of like yeah sorry I just brought you to
eternal life of killing people
you know and her line was just like well
you know I could never get my [__]
together by Tuesday anyways and that's
how the movie ended and a lot of movies
ended like that it was [__] fantastic
I was telling you guys I watched the
ending of Hooper
spoiler alert
the guy doesn't like
apologizes to him and asked him to
accept his apology
Bert turns around looks right down the
barrel of the camera Smiles at you as
the audience member and then punches the
guy in the face and knocks him out his
friends all laugh they all put their
arms around each other and they walk by
the camera and Bert looks right into the
camera gives the okay sign and it freeze
frames and that's the end of the [__]
movie
foreign
sounds like a shitty movie
you know I'm not gonna lie to you A lot
of it didn't age well but like you got
to understand what movies were before
that like nobody was that I guess that
was irreverent I don't know what it was
was [__] amazing though when I
watched it I was like that's how they
ended it
and we are [__] audio can you guys
because I'm watching a lot of movies
lately I don't know why
I'm going through this uh you know back
in therapy I'm trying to [__] get rid
of the fog he'll never really get rid of
it you just learn how to live with it
um
I've been going through all of this [__]
and um
so I've been watching movies for
whatever reason
and I always watch the old ones because
I like the cars and that type of stuff
but if you guys like give me your like
top five movies all time and then top
five what the [__] endings and it can
even be like a what the [__]
like great ending
you know like when Sylvester Stallone
in that movie where he had the beard and
the guys like sneaking in to kill that
chick
washing the dishes
and then he [__] turned you know the
chick turns around and it's it's it's
Sylvester Stallone and drag with his
with his like you know when Hulk Hogan's
a bad guy the Blackbeard he's got like a
Blackbeard
close like that you know but no yellow
[__] uh Fu Manchu blonde
that was a great ending I remember that
so anyway we went from those movies we
saw a disco movie if anybody can find
the name of that movie came about 78.79
so they were totally like basically
exploiting disco for as much as they
could
um
then I think the next what did we see I
used to know this we saw stripes we saw
Scarface we saw Jaws they brought Jaws
back to theaters because Jaws 2 was
coming out I know we saw that
uh
uh yeah we just immediately went to like
rated R movies my parents were just like
[__] this
we saw Shockey's machine
you know we did see Raiders of the Lost
Ark
uh but we didn't see Star Wars
when did I finally see Star Wars I think
I saw Star Wars when Empire Strikes Back
came
when that came out then they brought
back Star Wars but I saw Empire first
and I liked that and I saw Star Wars
and uh somewhere in that when they're
out there on the desert I just [__]
I checked out
um
yeah so I think that's what basically
what we saw then I just started seeing
all the Brat Pack movies as I became a
teenager
Breakfast Club
uh and then other ones Weird Science and
all of that then I was just Off to the
Races with whatever the [__] I wanted to
watch but when my parents took us to
movies we went to two kid movies and
then it was just all Al Pacino Burt
Reynolds
Bill Murray
um
just [__] insane [__] that you
probably shouldn't have seen at that age
it was awesome though
um I remember when Saturday Night Fever
came back they brought that back for
whatever reason at this local theater we
said this local theater in my town was
called the Oriental you know back when
you could just call [__] that right hey
let's go down to the Pollock taking a
picture it was called the Oriental
and uh
and it had like a little like this Cloud
that would float over the top like on
the ceiling you know what I mean which
was supposed to enhance like if you were
on drugs they're trying to get like the
kids to come down and they and they had
the rated R version
of uh Saturday Night Fever which I have
to see because that [__] movie is a
great movie that is a great movie
um
like to see that one again oh yeah I'll
tell you I'd like to see that one again
all right but anyway
uh Paul Anka let me get back to that
absolutely blew me away
um
he he just I met one he told this story
going you know when I was a kid
if you had you know he just told this
whole story about you know just slow
dancing and that was the big thing and
if the girl put her head on your
shoulder that was the biggest thing ever
the biggest thrill ever and he was
sitting and then I went home to back to
the apartment and I wrote down this
lyric and he just goes put your head on
my shoulder the [__] place goes nuts
I mean it was just
it was awesome and he looked great too
he had this
just all black suit with the tie the
pocket square he just looked he looked
sharp man he looked really sharp um
highly recommend it he's if you're out
here in La I think he's got a few more
dates out here out in the desert in uh
in March but my God
inspirational show all right with that
let's get to some of the reads here for
the week
the Andy reads the BT the beat what is
it BTK
foreign
torture kill what a [__] piece of
[__] oh really Bill do you think that
serial killer was a piece of [__] oh
there's a hot take
there's a [__] hot take all right let
me see here
all right live reads there they are oh
look who it is indochino you know I went
on indochino the other day because I
want to buy a Sam Rothstein style suit
uh they had a lot of classy [__] there I
think I'm gonna have to get mine
hey indochino are you listening can you
make me a Sam Rothstein suit for
Halloween I want to I want to dress like
him when right but when right before he
walks out to that El Dorado and gets
blown up
um
I'm a 54 year old man by the way
planning Halloween in February
Jesus Christ um if you rang in the new
year with someone special and 2023 will
be a new chapter in your relationship
indochino is ready to help you look your
best on your big day with their huge
variety of customizable details and
fabrics indochino can help you create
anything from made to mesha
Blazers and Suits to a custom portrait
worthy tuxedo all with no tailor
necessary indochino gives you everything
you need to create a custom suit
uh that's right for you oh and the Price
Is Right too and you're going to look
like a [__] million bucks all for
4.99
um prefer an in-person experience no
problem book an appointment at an
indochino showroom and work with an
expert style guide to take your
measurements and walk you through your
customization options then just sit back
and let the money roll in no just sit
back while your suit is made for you and
delivered straight to your door
indochino is a tailored experience at a
great price design suits uh design a
suit that looks design a look that suits
you perfectly [__] from the fabric to to
the cut suits started just 4.99 and
premium fitted shirts start at 89 you
can fine tune every detail if you're
ringing in 2023 with Wedding Bells ahead
start planning your custom look with
indochino
yeah [__] just get some [__] 4.99
tuxedo
go to indochine.com and use the code
Burr b-u-r-r and to get 10 off any
purchase at 3.99 or more that's
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
oh look who it is everybody
it's all butcher box it's a [__] Meat
Market
do they still say that
uh you're going down that Bar's a
[__] Meat Market
um
let's see uh butcher box takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
Meat and seafood you can trust 100
grass-fed beef organic chicken pork
raised crate free and wild caught
Seafood you don't know what it's gonna
do
hey do me a favor I want some eyes on
that Seafood over there okay they're
acting a little [__] squirrely
squirrels roll uh humanly humanely
raised humanly raised
they tucked them in humanely raised no
antibiotics or added [__] moans
they put the [__] and hormones those
piece of [__] Farmers ultimate
convenience get just what you want
delivered right to your doorstep free
shipping for the continental U.S and no
surprise freeze fees choose from a
variety of box plan options from curated
to customized and change your plan
whatever you want incredible value enjoy
a high range enjoy a range sorry if high
quality high quality cuts that are hard
to come by at the grocery store and an
amazing value butcher box is offering
our listeners one of their best [__]
deals yet 100 grass-fed chuck roast
uh it sounds like a show business keep
going for chuck roast chuck roast Chuck
Barris and a whole organic a whole
organic free chicken not a half one like
those other people whole organic chicken
for free when you join plus an
additional 20 20 off your first box sign
up today at butcherbox.com use the promo
code bird to get 100 grass fed chuck
roast and a whole chicken free in your
first box plus 20 off why has no fat
comic ever gone on sale stages chuck
chuck roast uh that's butcherbox.com and
use the code Burr to get this special
deal
all right what do we got next well we
got oh Simply Safe Simply Safe everybody
isn't that what we all want to be
Wanna Be isn't it
um today's episode is brought to you by
simply safe home security
would you do everything it took to
protect your family
of course you would well you know some
people wouldn't narcissists uh some
people take the bag of money and just
[__] leave that's why I recommend
Simply Safe home security they make it
easy to protect every inch of your home
that's what she said with ADV Advanced
security Tech powered by 24 7
Professional monitoring by the way have
I ever told you how much I love that's
what she said I always think it's funny
even if it isn't funny it just annoys
people I love it uh Simply Safe design
with Cutting Edge security technology
empowered by 24 7 Professional
monitoring in an emergency simply says
professional monitoring agents use fast
protection technology to capture
critical evidence and verify the threat
is real so you can get priority police
dispatch and they can start throwing
people off your [__] roof 24 7
Professional monitoring service costs
under a dollar a day less than half the
price of a traditional home security
system and it's almost enough money for
a New York Post
[__] post is almost four bucks out
here
um I am an old man I will [__]
Shuffle down to a grocery store buy a
newspaper go into a coffee shop
get a [__] cappuccino and sit there
and read gossip about celebrities and a
sports page I mean I
is anything better than that morning
little stack of pancakes they wouldn't
hurt uh you can lock your and unlock
your doors access your cameras in arm
and disarm your system from anywhere
see that name's Simply Safe editor's
Choice customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com go today and claim a free
indoor security camera plus 20 off your
order with interactive monitoring that's
simplysafe.com there's no safe
like simply safe
anyways you know what's one of the
stupidest things ever is reading a
newspaper when you live on the [__]
West Coast
you know I mean it's like by the time
you read it by the time you get up and
read the [__] thing it's already the
half the day half of the next day
that didn't even happen yet when that
paper was printed what they're talking
about is happening
but whatever
I enjoy it
I tell you what I don't enjoy is how my
[__] garage with this [__] heater
either sorry I didn't mean to slam that
down well I meant to slam it down I
wasn't thinking about your ears is he
the hottest [__] or it starts to get
cold
but God damn it I'm a man of a certain
[__]
all right the heat is coming on the heat
is
[Music]
caught up in the action I was [__]
picked again all right
the Monday morning podcast content for
February 6th everybody
uh great emails okay rugby oh boy we
have started something here with this
rugby [__]
um
by the way you know all of these sports
that I make fun of I'm just trying to
get you guys going I I respect all of
these so like just have fun with this
okay I watched it from part of a Premier
League game I turned it on at 75 minutes
and it was one nil
and I'm just saying this is this is this
is the game the whole world loves
they love sitting there for a [__]
hour and a half to see the ball go in
the net one time
they understand that less is more
you know
they must look at American basketball
like where's the [__] excitement the
[__] ball goes in
the bloody ball goes through the [__]
net every five [__] seconds all right
rugby everybody
um dear bill I am a kiwi
who lives and breathes rugby
I love that they say I'm a kiwi like New
Zealand you gotta [__] understand
that you know most people don't even
know who you are
all right what they think about when
they think of New Zealand is they think
Lord of the Rings
they think Fantasia
they think Adam and Eve they don't even
know what the [__] it is and I'll tell
you that's a great thing
I'm jealous of these off the [__]
radar countries
New Zealand
Australia
Canada and they get all [__] upset
too Iceland if you say they're off the
radar it's a good [__] thing nobody's
paying attention when was the last time
somebody bombed New Zealand
I don't want to give anybody any ideas
I'm just saying it's a [__] Paradise
but having said that you know I'm a kiwi
I don't even know what a kiwi is I I did
when I went over there I already forgot
I know it's some sort of fruit
sort of looks like an old turd but it's
green on the inside
um as it overs
um as an overseas listener my knowledge
of the American Sports is pretty much
limited to what you talk about on your
podcast well I will tell you this our
sports are probably just as dumb as
yours uh you appear to have an
encyclopedia encyclopedic knowledge I
did I don't know anybody's name for the
last
20 years I don't know what happened
somewhere in the in the 2000s
I just I don't know I got too busy I was
drinking I you know all right where I'm
at here um
I understand most Americans don't know
or care about rugby I currently live in
Canada and nobody
cares about it there uh when you said
Americans are no good at rugby because
they don't care I wonder if it also if
it's also that they don't care because
they're no good at it
now
that's not it dude come on dude we
[__] crush it
every time there's the Olympics we
[__] crush it just stop it all right
just stop it okay we have an
unbelievable [__] athletes here and
we have an endless amount of money that
we print with no gold behind it if we if
we actually if we gave a [__]
I remember LeBron James said that one
time when they were talking about the
scoring title when he early on
they asked him about this other player
because LeBron was passing a lot
and he just looked at him he just said
listen if I gave a [__]
you know if I really wanted that I could
get it all right so
I'm just saying if we gave a [__]
um anyhow the Rugby World Cup is the
third biggest sporting event by ticket
sales after the Olympics and the soccer
World Cup well I can't think of three
more boring things in the [__] world
oh my God skeet shooting on skis
I mean
I'm just talking personally I always try
to get into the Olympics I just I you
know then I'll just I'll watch something
[__] weird
I like curling
okay I like the Olympic hockey sorry I'm
in comedian mode here I respect all of
those I'm just saying like
rugby is that big rugby has hundreds of
thousands of players all over the world
you know and
around the world a billion Spectators
for the World Cup
all right well what does the Super Bowl
get wait a minute hang on a second hang
on a [__] second
how come on how many people watch the
Super Bowl
it says come on how many people I I did
see
all right it says 92 million I didn't
like that answer hang on a second
92 million okay worldwide
let's see if that's worldwide
oh [__] they just recorded that I am so
bad at these [__] things
how many people worldwide are watching
the Super Bowl every year
okay there you go over 208 million all
right
give me a [__] break buddy
over 208 million people watch a sport
that's only in our country rugby is all
over the world and you can only come up
with a billion
the [__] out of here
get the F all right Jesus you see it's
all how you look at the numbers sir
you know
I mean a billion people yeah that's very
respectable I find it weird that you
landed right on a billion that sounds
like sort of a
estimate rather than the 208 million
that I had which sounded a lot more
believable to me anyway it it's not some
minority sport
it kind of is though dude I [__] when
I travel around the world around the
world
I see more goddamn [__]
I see more [__] stores selling Yankee
[__] overseas than I see any rugby [__]
maybe I just don't know that I'm looking
at I see all kinds of soccer [__]
I can't remember the last time I don't
know
when was the last time that a bunch of
Spectators killed each other at a
[__] rugby game I don't remember that
maybe it happened
I don't know Bill maybe you could
[__] stop being an American [__] and
open your [__] eyes all right I can
try that
um
I don't know why some people like to
compare it
in with the NFL well because it's the
same game without pads
in a lot of ways right
I mean you you're just running the
wishbone the whole [__] game
um they are completely different sports
and I don't think anyone at the elite
level has succeeded in transitioning
from one to the other
um
yeah well I mean that they're two
different they are two different sports
but you can see how they're related
you can kind of see how we we sort of
did we took soccer and combined it with
rugby and came up with American football
and everybody has a problem with it for
some reason around the world
um anyway my girlfriend started watching
rugby with me 20 years ago and she's
still your girlfriend dude geez you're
[__] stringing her along and now
she's a huge fan now my wife okay there
we go we watch games together every
weekend it's the greatest sports
greatest sport so there I like the so
there
um dude I gotta be honest with you when
I was [__] in Ireland and they were
having uh when rugby was on I would
watch it and I loved it I loved it it's
[__] brutal it's a [__] brutal
sport NFL football used to be a brutal
sport but then
you know all of these guys were dying in
their 50s and 60s now I'll Enlighten you
[__] overseas as you guys all think
because they have helmets on
you know and pads on that they're a
bunch of [__] [__] well uh what is
the average lifespan
you know I don't see anybody going like
[__] they tackle with their shoulders
you know they're not slamming their
[__] heads I know what happens that
happens in every sport but they're not
doing it on purpose
and I don't want to hear your [__]
fish tales about oh yeah they do they're
[__] nut I've watched the game
I've watched the game it's it's you know
what it's like
it's kind of like the difference between
watching like when you watch like boxing
and they have gloves on or the UFC
it's not as bad as watching people bare
knuckle punch each other
in the [__] head and I don't know why
because all it does all the [__]
glove does is protect the hand
you know what I mean
it's like
you've seen people's faces at the end of
a boxing match they're [__] horrific
and
you can literally knock somebody out
open hand just slapping across the face
if you [__] hit them the right way
and their brain slams and you know your
brain's sitting there in the fluid there
right you got you got a basically a snow
globe inside of your head
um
so that's the myth that I would like to
dispel to all you [__] around the
world [__] is
um
we actually had to change
the rules of the game and how we played
it to the point that's not even like an
All-Star game anymore they play like
flag football because nobody wants to go
in there and risk getting [__] CTE
there was like
football players retiring going nuts
there was a guy killed his whole family
on the Chiefs a long time ago uh one of
the guys that played with Len Dawson
um
just [__] had major major brain
damage
um I remember seeing another football
player had his foot cut off on purpose
because the pain was just so [__]
unbearable after a while
uh
you know they don't live a long time so
say what you want about it as you don't
play professional football or rugby talk
about what [__] they are they are not
um
and I think they would kick the [__] out
of any rugby player out there there we
go that'll get things going uh kid gets
locked in shipping container
Bill did you hear about this I'm [__]
with you about that rugby [__] by the
way I don't think that they would kick
the [__] out I think they're equal level
lunatics and everybody deserves respect
and if I wasn't such an [__] I
wouldn't have started this conversation
going in this direction or did I start
it
maybe you guys started it I don't know
kid gets locked in shipping container
Bill did you hear about this no I did
not
I don't watch the news uh I'd sleep
outside for the rest of my life if this
happened to me a 15 year old boy who
locked himself in a shipping container
during a game of hide and seek has been
found a week later in a different
country
per Malaysian news agency
bernama in the India times the teenage
boy has only been ins identified by his
first name Fahim
and was discovered in a shipping
container in Malaysia six days after he
fell asleep inside of the container
in the city
of Chittagong Bangladesh on January
January 11th
Bangladesh where the [__] is that
is that up near India I know roughly
where Malaysia is Singapore Philippines
all right I gotta look this anyways
um
where the [__] am I
six days after he fell asleep inside the
container
blah blah blah on January 11th the boy
was just believed to have entered the
container fell asleep and found himself
here
said the Malaysian home minister
to tuck sarri say foot in
Ismail
Jesus Christ
what if you don't pronounce his name
right do you get put to death uh bill
you can you imagine dealing with
anyone's [__] about anything after
having gone through that
well I like how they acted like he slept
for six days
um
what did he do for water after three
days no water you're dead
that's [__] Wild
uh maybe he drank his own tears I have
no idea that's [__] terrifying
well at least he's all right my God I
can't remember what his parents were
thinking where the hell is he they
probably thought he was kidnapped or
killed or something [__]
all right as a parent I don't need
emails like that
um
wait now this he said he fell asleep in
there
he locked himself in a shipping
container during a game of hide and go
seek
all right I'm I'm back I don't know what
happened I hit something that stopped it
and I really wish I could stay calmer in
moments like that rather than
like my hand still hurts from how hard I
was slapping my table going goddamn
[__] piece of technology [__] sucking
[__] [__] whatever the hell I said
whatever childish [__] [__] I just
did my neighbors much think I'm [__]
nuts hey forget about my wife okay
um
all right I was talking about this kid
getting locked in the container I don't
know where it cut out
all right really quickly a 15 year old
boy who locked himself in a shipping
container uh during a game of hide and
seek has been found a week later in a
different country per Malaysian news
agency bernama and the India times the
teenage boy who has only been identified
by his first name Fahim
great [__] name that's like Bob or
Bill over there and was discovered in a
shipping container in Malaysia six days
after he fell asleep inside the [__]
container in the city of Chittagong
Bangladesh on January 11th the quote the
boy was just believed to have entered
the container fell asleep and found
himself here said Malaysian
home minister this is my second time
trying to do this right this is this
guy's name
the tuck Siri
Ismail
one two three four five
names that guy's not [__] around bill
can you imagine dealing with anyone's
[__] about anything after having gone
through that
uh my thing was I thought after three
days you you know with no water
that you would uh
you know
expire you can go like whatever
a little over a month with no food but I
think no water after three days you're
[__] so maybe it rained or some [__]
I don't know what as a 15 year old
I just can't imagine being in there
going where am I going
am I I must be going somewhere at least
that the country's friendly enough with
that they they can trade with them
that's what I'd be worried about
aside from dying
Jesus [__] Christ
um
well I'm glad he's all right I don't
like as a parent I don't want to get
emails like this this is [__] brutal
that's all I think about is my kids you
know earlier today we were like killing
some time
and
you know
trying to get the kids tired wear them
out or whatever and we brought him into
this department store we were walking
around and I just the whole time I'm
there I just [__]
I like going to like CIA [__]
Secret Service [__] mode well I just
don't let my kids out of my sight at all
at [__] all
um somebody told me some [__]
horrific story of somebody trying to
take their kid
and what you do is when you can't find
your kid you just yell out what clothing
they're wearing you know red shirt
[__] whatever pants that's what she
did
and the woman that was trying to take
her just let go over and [__]
ran out of the store or some [__] like
that it's [__] terrifying but it's
something you do have to deal with all
right that's not funny but
it is what it is all right wearing red
skin gear
dear Ginger mcfuck face
uh I am writing seeking your advice on
fashion as you're obviously an expert in
that area all right take it easy I was
born and raised in the DC area and I'm a
dice Die Hard DC Sports Fan one of my
hobbies is I love to collect vintage
clothing items from all DC teams I'd be
careful with that and not for the
reasons you think it's just someday
you're going to have all of that [__]
and it's going to mean so much to you
and it's just going to be taking up all
this space and it gets to the point
where you start to wish that you didn't
[__] do it
um and then that's when you've got to
hire a stranger to sell it because it
means too much to you anyway the tricky
one he's this person says is the
Redskins there are loads of nice
Redskins starter jackets jerseys Etc out
there that I'd love to add to my
collection the problem is my girlfriend
thinks I shouldn't be wearing red skin
items she supports my hobby and even
looks for things for me but she doesn't
love the idea of me wearing any red skin
gear I grew up with the Redskins and
have no ill will ill will towards any
ethnicities or group I just purely like
the item because they look cool and
remind me of my childhood plenty of
people in the area still wear Redskins
gear but I worry I will piss off my girl
if I buy anything Redskins uh is she
overthinking it or am I just out of
touch if the Patriots changed their name
because the Patriots Were Somehow people
found it offensive would you still wear
Patriot stuff old school Patriots stuff
you mean curious on what you think
thanks and go [__] yourself uh the big
thing that I got out of that was
you know you want to do something but
you're worried that you're going to piss
off your girlfriend I mean basically as
long as you're not going out to go [__]
another woman like why has she had this
level of say in your hobby
you know
I mean I don't I I don't think it's a
problem I mean if you just like it
because you grew up with it and I don't
know
I mean I don't think it's that big a
deal and I also think that like
I guess maybe if you like wore it to a
Redskins game and and like you're doing
it
with like malice
like [__] you I don't think you know I
don't care if this offends you
blah blah blah blah but you know if
you're just like collecting it and [__]
like that I mean I don't think it's a
problem if you wear it out or whatever
and you're wearing it because Joe Gibbs
had it it reminds you of that era I
don't think it's a problem uh
uh and um
I think there's a lot of this type of
stuff these these grand gestures but
there's
to make up
for genocide and slavery and all this
type of stuff but I don't think there's
much work being done on individuals to
change
the way that they think
um
and I don't you know
it's not that the people in power don't
care it's
no it is that they don't care it's not
that they want us to be fighting with
each other as everybody says I just
think they're just so focused on [__]
money that they just don't give a [__]
so it's kind of up to you as an
individual
to go out and uh not be an [__] so
that's all you have to do it has nothing
to do with your [__] football jacket
so if that's what you're into I mean
I mean granted you're asking a white guy
I I if I was you I would ask somebody
who's a Native American that's what I
would do so as a white guy the only
thing I can relate to in that that uh
that that stood out to me was that
you're gonna piss off your girlfriend if
you [__] buy some stupid football
jacket
you know what I mean it's like all right
okay well let's do a little little Tit
for Tat here there [__] titties there
little titties for uh nuts here how
about uh I won't buy this jacket you
[__] lay off the shoes
as I say thank you we said the same
thing
would you like to meet the people that
actually make those shoes and see the
living conditions they're in what are
you [__] supporting all right flying
stories
all right hi Bill the flying stories are
great just wanted to say uh when you've
been when you've been coming to La for
IVF over the last five years and until
the first
mr15 month year old came along in the
covid
dude how big are your thumbs when you
[__] texted this thing
what the [__] I mean is this like some
sort of Aviation talk that I don't
understand
we've been coming to La for over the
last five years and until
the first
Mr 15 month year old came along in the
covid winter of 2020 2021. I don't know
what any of that means uh we got to
we got out to all different areas around
Southern California
there's no capital letters there's no
like periods or anything okay uh the
flying stories are relatable and I love
hearing about the helicopter experience
your description of approaching
different airports or roaming around
different areas was interesting even
suspenseful I used to love flying the
helicopters in GTA Grand Theft Auto and
once hired a helicopter to take
fly around Melbourne to get aerial
photographs one of the scariest things
I've ever done flying on an
on an r44 yeah that would be scary
scarier than in one uh with the door off
oh yeah banking over to get the photos
yeah that's that gets a little uh
it gets a little hairy
um you know what's weird is if you're
looking long out the windshield you
don't really think about how high you up
you are but when you look to the side
look down at the ground that's when I
always think [__]
uh banking over to get photos straight
down over skyscrapers in the city yeah
dude yeah
that literally I don't know that makes
my palm sweat I that [__] freaks me out
I I'm a big fan of doors on flying uh
the CBD is a major airport path to Tola
Marie airport Melbourne uh biggest
airport we would duck in and out of the
approach path to allow 737s and 777s and
A3 a380s is that I said go through Jesus
Christ as we left a smaller airport
north of Melbourne yeah if you get
underneath those things the [__] uh
the vortices if I remember from my
training
um
that gets a little crazy like you know
the times I've soloed into like Burbank
Airport they'll be like you're number
two after the JetBlue or the Southwest
or whatever the [__] is landing there
and how it works if you're a lighter
aircraft
um maybe it works I think it probably
works with all aircraft no that wouldn't
make sense they probably just have the
spacing
uh it's basically if you're in a little
[__] [__] helicopter like me and
you're behind a Southwest aircraft
that's Landing first what you do is you
just you just watch where they land
they usually land you know right on the
numbers basically a little bit after and
what you do is you just come in
above that and you land Beyond it and
that way you'd never get into their wash
because it's enough to push you down and
knock you out of the sky basically which
is sort of terrifying in itself so
um
I do remember the first time I was
trying to solo
up along
um
the coast down Manhattan Beach and you
go through you got to pass through the
Bravo airspace of uh LAX
I was at King's habit and then I got to
Manhattan Beach and I made my call La
helicopters helicopter
Manhattan Beach Pier uh
uh requesting transitioning through the
Bravo
was it North North Shoreline transition
through the Bravo at about low 100 150
which is 150 feet it's basically the
beginning of Magnum PI is what you do
and of course my [__] radio is
cutting out I think I was just too low
and I was inexperienced I didn't know
what was going on and I just knew the
guy talked long enough
I'd even think well I didn't hear the
clearance so say it again I just thought
well
he must have told me to [__] do a
holding patch so I just did a holding
pattern
and I think I accidentally went higher
so I could hear him and as I was doing
the holding pattern I saw one of those
double decker Jets taking off you know I
was going out the [__] like France or
something
gonna go fly to [__] Moscow
so that would have been interesting
um but you know every pilot has those
[__] stories is the only way you know
you learn by [__] up you just don't
like because here's the thing is is as
much as that might upset you guys to
hear
that story it was like there was no
[__] way I was going to go into Bravo
airspace unless I clearly heard the guy
read my whole tail number and say that I
was cleared in
so
um I was more freaking out going like
okay my radio isn't working so what do I
do now I squawk uh what is it [__]
seven
oh Jesus I don't even I should brush up
on this stuff
what the [__] do you squawk
75 stay alive
76 need a fix
uh yeah I need a fix would be 76 or
something like that
uh
Jesus I should brush up on that um
anyway glad you wrote in sir uh 7600 I
think that's what you squat right
I'm a helicopter I'll just [__] set
it down
get out my phone look it up and then
I'll [__] do it
um anyway uh joking of course as we left
Melbourne's small airport the pilot told
me to look around and speak up if I saw
another aircraft coming at us and if I
didn't have enough to think about it as
if I didn't have enough to think about
so we land and I had to just sit for a
while just processing it all I really
just killed the momentum of your story
laughable thinking about it though it
was only 35 minutes in the area in the
air ha ha no dude that's [__] scary
because that's all analog gauges like
if you got the Gammon 750 or the 1000 or
something whatever the [__] I got the
750 it shows you where the traffic is so
you at least know where to look
nothing is Fail-Safe but um
that would have been a great story if I
just read it straight through sorry
about that buddy all right seeking
wisdom from an old Ginger it was still a
great story by the way keep those
Aviation ones coming in
um
uh
uh dear Bill Burr I am a 23 year old
male who feels lost in direct
directionless for my future hey buddy
welcome to the party You Are Not Alone
most people at 23 myself included that's
exactly where I felt
probably the most lost because I was
after college and I was just like what
did I major in what the [__] am I doing
um anyway I am currently working
full-time and finishing my master's
program part-time however for the
longest time I've felt a strong desire
to pack up everything and move to a new
area
I'm from upstate New York and have lived
in the same zip code my whole life I'm
not sure where my desire to move came
from
it has always been something I wanted to
do I don't want to ignore this feeling
because I know I would look back and
regret it if I never tried right now my
plan is to finish school save what I can
and move to a different state once I
graduate however I have recently told a
couple of friends and my siblings this
ideas and they all took a [__] on it
yeah well that's what people do
that's something that you're going to
learn a lot like hey you know what I
want to do and and you know especially
if you tell it to somebody who's not
doing anything
they're gonna [__] on it take a big
[__] [__] right on it uh my friends
have told me it doesn't seem like a good
idea because I won't know anyone yeah
these are all fearful thoughts of people
who are afraid to go anywhere I have no
family anywhere else and will be
abandoned in them I have no real reason
to move but I've always wanted to live
on my own in a new area while I still
have the freedom to do so this sounds
like a great idea to me I don't have
anyone older than me to get outside an
outside opinion on this so I thought I
would email an old bald dude for some
advice well you come to the right place
I would appreciate any advice or
guidance on the situ on this situation I
think that's [__] great if that's
what you feel like you want to do you
should do it and there's a way to do
both
why don't you take a trip somewhere
you know just you can literally get on a
[__] train and pretty much go
anywhere
and you know bring like a backpack you
can go real cheap
I don't know where you live where's the
nearest Big City
do a little research of some things you
want to go to here's one if you're a
sports fan if you live outside Chicago
go and go to a White Sox or a Cubs game
live outside New York just take the
train go to a game by yourself gives a
[__] go get a sandwich
hail a cab
just you know
go down there and just see how it feels
and uh I would kind of go from there
um traveling is an unbelievable thing
to do for you as a human being it opens
up
it opens up your mind and I think it
makes you a better person if you're if
your mind if your ears are open when you
go there I mean if you travel like most
New Yorkers do like New York people live
in New York City are the worst [__]
Travelers I've ever met in my life
because they get upset everywhere they
go that there aren't as many buildings
and they can't get this exact same food
that they have where they live which is
[__] hilarious because the the whole
purpose of traveling is different
experiences to experience something
different they're like how come you
ain't got a [__] slice of peach
daughter my [__] neighborhood
they're the worst they're like country
people that live in the city exact same
mentality is somebody who lives in is is
somebody looks in the middle like why
the [__] I need to go anywhere I'll get
everything I need right here I ain't
going in that damn city with all them
gender neutral [__] transitional
[__] people those idiots
um I'm not saying you're an idiot if you
stay where you're at it's if you [__] on
somebody else because they want to leave
um well let me just talk to this kid
here when somebody shits on your idea
you just have to know that what they're
saying has nothing to do with you it has
to do with what you're how what you're
doing makes them feel
so right there you just cancel all of
that
all right let me ask you this if one of
somebody you knew said hey you know what
I always wanted to start a band or I
always wanted to do this or I always
wanted to go here would you [__] on it
that the answer is no
then you're a good guy and you should
get some better [__] friends
you don't need to get better friends
just I remember a long time ago Tom Papa
the great Tom Papa once told me he said
you know I realized in life whenever I
was making a big move people's reaction
to it
had nothing to do with what I was doing
it had to do with them and where they
were and if they felt stuck they you
know you you leaving makes them kind of
feel like left behind I think
or something but who gives a [__]
all right I say you do it and I would I
would start
you know as you're getting through
your master's degree which I relate to
that because you know I had to work my
way through college
and then pay off the loans and do all of
that [__] so it took me forever to get
through college uh
uh I didn't I didn't finish my all my
classes until I was 24 and a half and
then I I walked when I was 25 but I was
out in December of 92 and then I just
went through the formality in June so
you're ahead of the game when it comes
to that [__] but like you're still
really really really young
and uh
a great way to find where you want to go
is to take a couple of small trips
you know and check it out and
it you know you could end up being like
you know what maybe I'll just stay where
I'm at and I'll just I'll travel more or
you could be like you know what there's
just something about this city that I
connect with for as much as I [__] on
New York City I really connected with
that City
and then somewhere in the 2000s I
connected more with LA
and now I keep having a reoccurring
fantasy of living in the middle of
nowhere sitting on a porch
drinking coffee smoking cigars reading a
newspaper and having a little bit of
whiskey and just not doing anything and
uh but I have kids so
you know I'm not I'm locked down
[Laughter]
so you're 23 you got your whole life
ahead of you this is the one of the best
times in your life they're all great
times in your life if you know how to
live though
um if you are enjoying them you know if
a four-wheel doesn't four wheeler
doesn't backfire in your [__] ear but
you know what my ears kind of going down
hopefully hopefully I didn't [__] it up
whatever
just something you deal with right
um anyway that's it everybody enjoy the
podcast
uh don't listen to your friends if they
should on your drapes all right that's
it go [__] yourselves and I'll talk to
you on Thursday
I hate this part where I gotta Slide the
mouse across that's so anti-climactic